good citizens of the reject Nation I just got
out of black panther wakanda forever and I am
a bit uh overwhelmed admittedly I'm gonna go all
my positives first and then I've only got a couple
qualms I'm gonna save that for the end all this
is non-spoiler by the way this is a movie that is
a mix of a barrage of Sight and Sound and stimuli
mixed with moments of pure poignant sadness it is
so sorrowful it is so intentionally remorseful and
and thoughtful that it's not quite like anything
else in the MCU and all of phase four has been
very intentionally about rebirth and death and
the experience of mourning and what it means to
be alive and what it means to not and they had
the thankless task of not only following up
one of the greatest comic book films of all
time one of the most unique comic book films of
all time but they then had to do it without Chad
Boseman in a phase about loss needed to address
the loss of the Black Panther and I think that
not only did they handle that masterfully but
it was able to illustrate so much more and
it's one of those you know diamonds come from
pressure situations where there's so much Beauty
in the sorrow of this story and the pressure they
were under the agony it must have been to make
this movie translated into some really spectacular
art they have introductions to uh ironheart one of
my favorites newer Marvel characters they have
introductions to namel one of my all-time most
he's not one of my favorites that's not fair to
say but he's a character I always look forward to
seeing how he's dealt with he's a character that's
hard to write he's a character that isn't easy to
navigate so when he's great I'm thrilled because
it's a character I want to be great so they have
a character that's very divisive by his nature in
the story that's handled pretty magnificently they
have uh a a nation that is uh in mourning that is
also dealing with the ramifications of how black
panther ends and they juggle all of that while
telling a very important story that deals with
says this is a movie I'm more excited to talk
spoilers about than most because the the things
that juggles and things it deals with I I
didn't know going into it I got off social
media the weeks leading up to this to make sure I
didn't know anything but most of all I love that
as a comic book fan there were a lot of really
really impactful images that I didn't see in any
marketing whatsoever there's a lot of imagery that
comes straight from the comic books that ties more
directly into the the iconography of black panther
than I think even the first one did so there's a
lot of things that I really was impressed by as a
comic fan to to get the movie itself has a ton of
action set pieces but what I loved most was the
the fast and furious with all the family I got to
experience Humanity through super human
circumstances the thing I love about these
movies is you know they're often moral and
ethical stories told through the Trojan Horse
of a blockbuster this one leans way more
drama than Blockbuster this one leans way
more introspective than explosion and when it
does go explosion it does it very well I don't
think there's anything quite to compare it to
except for that it might have more DNA with
eternals than say Iron Man but
I think that's its strength
um I think it does what eternals did whilst moving
at a more feverish Pace I think that when it stops
to really breathe it kind of is more aggressive
in its own way even even the pauses are like you
can't rest the movie it feels like someone uh
they'll wait is on your chest for nearly three
hours it is a very emotionally draining experience
and I mean that in a very positive way I don't
think this is a movie that is going to be in the
background of any party this isn't a movie that's
going to be washed casually this is a film to
be immersed in to be experienced in this is
overwhelming uh so those are those are my
positives uh I I'm trying to again this is
probably the movie I'm the most excited to give my
my spoiler discussion on because all the things I
want to talk about are they were kept for me and
I love that um the things I didn't didn't love 100
were a lot of the time it felt like they needed to
do a lot and they would leave a moment that I was
relishing in and and there would be a bombardment
of of Sight and Sound in a way that felt like I
could have used like another 10 seconds and I
know that's uh that sounds like splitting hairs
but just a couple moments felt like they needed
to get to a thing instead of letting me feel
the thing but like that's looking for a flaw and
then the main flaw had the the one Central flaw
um was that to me the personification of Namor was
just different than how I perceived the character
the way I read Namor is um a certain type of
snooty that I didn't quite feel and and I want to
dive deep into that in a more spoiler conversation
but there were moments I didn't feel quite like
anymore and it's it's no problems I have with
the actor it it's no problems I have with the way
he portrayed it but I feel like the story didn't
allow for the way Neymar feels to me now that said
because the personification they chose and because
of the storyline they chose it was able to tell
arguably a more important story um because of
the story they chose and the way Namor was um
delivered I do feel like we got more of a look at
Humanity again Humanity through super Humanity if
Namor was the way I perceive him then a lot of the
the beats that really hit me wouldn't have worked
um so I think it was definitely a juice worth
the squeeze situation where even my biggest flaw
which is that I didn't feel like every moment of
Namor felt like the common character the reasoning
behind it was very justified in that some of my
favorite moments were because of these choices
this is a very hard thing to to not spoil but um I
really loved how they navigated all of the you've
seen in the trailer's rivalry and I love how they
navigated the world in the UN and the greater
World At Large and I will say to wrap this up that
it is probably my favorite World building within
the MCU that feels like the world is growing in
gravitas versus it growing for the sake of growing
out the MCU it feels like the world is growing not
the universe is growing it feels like the culture
is more deep it feels like the other cultures are
more Versed and and have more of a tangibility to
them as opposed to just expanding out references
and expanding out things that we want to see as
fans this makes the world much more tangible
and so it's huge World building but not in the
traditional MCU sense but in the traditional movie
making sense that's something I really appreciate
and enjoyed this movie definitely uh wrecked me
uh I was definitely like I said emotional for
three hours and I really love the world of builds
the cultures it showed the costume design as ever
Ruth Carter just crushed the acting as ever like
Angela Bassett here is such a Powerhouse she is so
so good in this uh Leticia Wright as shuri I mean
Winston Dukes Baku is a scene stealer at all times
just Powerhouse is all around in the production
design the world's again the world's built here
like nothing else that is going to do it for this
spoiler-free review that was very hard to keep
spoiler free the depths of the world the acting
the ability to balance real themes the navigating
of a very very difficult thing and overall the way
it made you feel is so unique to this film and the
things that juggled um yeah I'm very excited
to see this again tomorrow but kind of forever